Continue from the last section or load the level named 04 Cinematics Render.
If you need to, select and open the level sequence that is in this level.
As you may have noticed it from the last section, Movie Render Queue is accessible from Sequencer,
but it is also available in the Windows menu under Cinematics.
If these options are not present when using a different project, make sure you visit the Plugins dialog,
and ensure Movie Render Queue is active.
The Additional Render Passes option is currently in beta and is used to create mats, which is not needed for this project even though the plugin is enabled.
When you start Movie Render Queue from the Windows menu, it starts with a blank job list.
But if you start it from within Sequencer, it picks up the level sequence you have already defined, in this case Sequencer Render.
Otherwise, you can add the sequence using the Render button, thus creating a batch render job.
If you expand the job entry, you'll see the three camera shots defined in the level sequence.
All three are active, but you can disable one or more that you don't need to render.
For this demo, I'll keep all three active, although it will take longer to render.
To adjust render parameters, you can click on Save Config. Ultimately, you'll be able to save and load your own presets.
Here you can start making adjustments such as the output type, currently set to JPEG Sequence.
You can opt for something better such as a PNG or EXR sequences, but JPEG will be fine for now.
You can edit the parameters of the deferred rendering or add to them.
This is where you could add path tracing to your render queue, for example, as long as ray tracing is enabled in your project.
Another option would be to add a lighting-only entry to the queue to render a sequence like the style you see in Viewport mode.
This could potentially be used later as a multiplier layer in the compositing software.
Under Output, you can set things like an output folder, resolution and frame rate, among other options.
Perhaps more importantly, you can add parameters to control quality such as anti-aliasing.
You can override the default anti-aliasing and increase the temporal count substantially to increase anti-aliasing quality. I'll go with a value of 32.
This will increase render time significantly, but will provide higher quality renders.
This number, like many numbers in UE5, should be kept to a power of 2.
Another quality control settings you can add is Games Override.
If nothing else, this option ensures Lot 0 for all meshes is active all the time, so meshes will remain in high quality display even if you're not close to them.
This entry also sets shadows in high quality mode, among other options.
Finally, add a Console Variables entry to the queue.
This allows you to specify console variables that will affect the rendering process only, not the project itself.
For example, you can add a couple of variable entries, one for the Bloom quality by entering r.bloomQuality,
and then setting its value to 5, the range being from 0 to 5.
I add another for Motion Blur quality by entering r.motionBlurQuality,
and setting its value to 4, this variable ranging from 0 to 4.
Once you have made your adjustments, you can opt to save the preset so you can use it again at a later time.
You can then accept the changes and go back to the main window.
At this time, you can elect to render locally or remote to send the job as a separate process and free your local resources.
For now, go ahead and render locally.
The render will be slow but mostly because it's rendering all 32 anti-aliasing subframes of roughly a thousand frames as defined by the Playback Area and Sequencer.
The estimated render time for the current camera shot is shown in the Preview window. I'll speed up the process.
The Low Quality label only refers to the current Preview window and does not denote the quality of the rendered frames to disk.
As it renders the sequence, you can view the results by visiting the Output folder and viewing one of the images.
You'll find out that the anti-aliasing is of far better quality than the screenshot tool gave us earlier.
Once all images are saved to disk, you can compile them together into an animation by using programs like Adobe Premiere or even Photoshop.
In Photoshop, you only need to open the first image and select the Image Sequence option.
Once loaded, make sure the timeline is displayed.
And then click the Play button to view the animation.
This brings us to the end of this class. Make sure you save your work and exit the project.